CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
Today we're going to talk
about some rules of logarithms
that you're going
to need to remember.
We're going to prove
why one of them is true,
and then I'm going to ask you
to use these rules to take
a derivative of a function.
So let's just look
at these rules first.
So I want to point out, as
I'm talking about these rules,
the first three are
written with natural log.
But one can also
write them in any base
as long as the base is the
same all the way across.
So in any legitimate
base that one
is allowed to use, so
with a positive base,
one can use it all
the way across instead
of the natural log.
So the first one says that
the natural log of a product
is equal to the sum
of the natural logs.
So natural log of M times N
is equal to the natural log
of M plus natural log of N.
The second one says the
natural log of a quotient
is equal to the difference
of the natural logs.
So natural log of
M divided by N is
equal to natural log of
M minus natural log of N.
This third one says that the
natural log of something raised
to a power is that
power, as a coefficient,
times the natural
log of the something.
So natural log of M to
the k is equal to k times
the natural log of M.
And what I want to point
out is that there's
a distinct difference
where the power is.
So if the power is inside the
argument then this rule holds,
but if the power is
outside the argument--
so if it's natural log of M, the
whole thing raised to a power--
this does not work.
This is not equal to
what's written above.
And then the third--
the fourth one, sorry.
The fourth one is a
change of base formula.
So if I have, if I have
log base something,
b-- maybe I want to
change the base-- of M,
I can rewrite that
in the base e.
I can write that
as natural log of M
divided by natural log of b.
And I want to point out,
a common mistake people
make is sometimes they confuse
the second and the fourth
because they both
have quotients.
But notice that
the second one is
the natural log of a
quotient, and the fourth one
is about the quotient
of natural logs.
So that's a distinct difference,
and hopefully then you
see that they are not--
these two statements are not,
in fact, the same statement.
So now what I'd like
to do is using what
we know about exponential
and log functions,
I want to prove number one.
So let's set out to do that.
Well, in order to make
this top line make sense
we know that M and N
have to be positive.
And so I can find--
actually, let
me write first what we're doing.
We're going to prove one.
So with M and N both positive
I can find values a and b such
that e to the a equals M and
e to the b is equal to N.
And let me just write
out also what that means.
Because exponential
and log functions
are inverses of
one another, this
means that a is equal
to natural log of M
and b is equal to
natural log of N.
So these are
equivalent statements.
This statement and this
statement are equivalent.
So now let's use
that information
to try and solve the problem.
To try and prove number one.
So the natural log of M
times N, well, what is that?
M is e to the a,
N is e to the b.
So I can write this as natural
log of e to the a times e
to the b.
What's e to the a
times e to the b?
This is where we use
our rules of exponents.
e to the a times e to the
b is e to the a plus b.
So this is natural log
of e to the a plus b.
And now, what's the point?
The point is that natural
log in exponential functions
are inverses of one another, or
natural log of e to the x is x.
So natural log of e to the
a plus b is just a plus b.
And I've already
recorded for you
what those are-- it's natural
log of M plus natural log of N.
So notice we've done
what we set out to do.
Natural log of the
quantity M times N
is equal to natural log of
M plus natural log of N.
And in a similar flavor
one could immediately
do number two, and number
three follows quite similarly,
as well.
It uses-- obviously,
these are going
to use different
rules for exponents
besides the product of
two exponential functions
is equal to the
sum of the powers.
It's going to use some
of those other rules.
And I believe that some
of these other things
might actually also be
proven in a later lecture
in the actual course.
So you'll see these.
But I would say, you might
want to try and prove two
and three, at
least, on your own--
might be helpful to look
at how those work using
the same kind of rules here.
So now what I'd like us to
do is using these rules,
I'd like us to
take a derivative.
So what I want us
to look at is y
equals the square root
of x times x plus 4.
And we'll just assume
that x is bigger than 0.
And I want you to find y prime.
Now you could do this just
brute force, cranking it out.
But I'd like you to try and
use the log differentiation
technique in order to
find this derivative.
I'll give you a moment to do
it and then I'll come back
and I'll show you how I do it.
OK.
Welcome back.
So I'm going to use the log
differentiation and the rules I
have on the side
of the board there
to take a derivative
to find y prime.
So first what we do is we
take the log of both sides
and then we use some of
the rules of logarithms
to simplify the expression
on the right-hand side.
So I will take natural log
y is equal to natural log
of the square root
of x times x plus 4.
Now square root-- wow,
sorry-- square root
is the power of something
raised to the 1/2.
Right?
That's what it means
to take a square root.
You can take this whole product
and raise it to the 1/2.
So I'm going to use
rule number three
and I'm going to bring that 1/2
that is a power out in front
of the log.
So I can rewrite this expression
as 1/2 log of this product.
That's one too many
parentheses, but that's OK.
OK.
So I have 1/2 the natural log of
the product of x and x plus 4.
So now I'm going to use
rule number one which
changes the product-- the
natural log of a product
into the sum of
the natural logs.
And I can rewrite this
as 1/2 natural log
x plus 1/2 natural log
the quantity x plus 4.
Essentially what
I'm doing here is
I have to distribute this
1/2 because I had one term,
and then I'm going to have two
terms that are added together,
but the 1/2 applies
to both of them.
So now I have this nice setup.
I have natural log of y is equal
to something in terms of x.
And now I can take the
derivative of a both sides.
Now remember, I want
to find y prime,
so there's some implicit
differentiation going on.
So let's just be
careful when we do that.
If I take the derivative of this
side I don't just get y prime,
I get y prime over y.
Where does that come from?
Well, d/dx of this
expression is the derivative
of the natural log
evaluated at y,
then times the derivative of y.
You've seen this, I
think, a lot by now,
but just to make sure you
understand where both of those
come from.
So when I take the derivative
here I get y prime over y.
When I take the derivative
here with respect to x, well,
derivative of natural log
of x is just 1 over x.
So I get 1 over 2x.
And then the derivative of
natural log of x plus 4,
if I use the chain
rule I get 1 over x
plus 4 times the derivative of
x plus 4, which is still just 1,
so I get 1 over
2 times x plus 4.
So now I wanted us
to find y prime.
So to find y prime I'm going
to move over a little bit more.
And just notice that y prime
is going to equal y times
all of that.
Well, I know y.
So I'm going to write what y is.
y is the square root of x times
x plus 4 times this quantity.
1 over 2x plus 1 over
2 times x plus 4.
So that's actually
one way to write
the derivative of y prime now--
or sorry, the derivative of y.
Now I could combine
these two fractions
into a single fraction
and try and make
it look a little bit nicer, or
I could just leave it this way.
This is technically
a derivative.
So if I started trying
to combine things
I might find out that
I could have just taken
the derivative the long way.
So this is a nice short
way to just get to a place
where I can start to
find out something
about the derivative of y.
So I guess I'll stop there.